[Musica]
due sono i miti su cui si è costruito
l'immaginare della mia generazione di
cinquantenne gli extraterrestri dei
nativi americani gli extraterrestri sono
in qualche modo una ipotesi noi non
abbiamo prove inconfutabili della loro
esistenza è piuttosto ingenuo pensare
naturalmente che ci siano dei marziani
con le antenne che alla guida di dischi
volanti vengano a invadere il nostro
pianeta però forse è ancora più ingenuo
immaginare che non esistano
nell'universo altre forme di vita
intelligente ammesso che l'intelligenza
sia un valore universale
certamente i latini americani invece
esistono o meglio dell'immagine del
comune esistevano non appartengono alla
dimensione delle ipotesi ma quella della
memoria una memoria che sprofonda nella
leggenda sono stati sterminati e oggi ci
sono poche unità che vivono in desolate
riserve indiane appunto che sono luoghi
di eterotopia per eccellenza è curioso
che due elementi così affini nella forza
con cui hanno alimentato il nostro
immaginario siano del tutto diversi
recenti the tc perché gli extraterrestri
sono freddi tecnologici futuribili privi
di sentimenti di passioni
e non hanno nessun legame con la natura
con il mondo animale per esempio invece
i nativi americani sono percepiti sono
raccontati come passionali ingenui
colorati arcaici spirituali con un
fortissimo rapporto col mondo animale e
con la natura e curioso che questo cielo
di roswell in new mexico che un cielo
strano sembra un tramonto spaccato in
due come un quadro di mark rothko al
contrario bellissimo secondo me è ver il
new mexico è una terra che sintetizza
queste due fortissime fonti del nostro
immaginario è l'unico luogo credo al
mondo in cui proprio a roswell che per
il resto è una cittadina noiosissima
bisognerebbe visitarla proprio per
vedere la noia della piccola città di
provincia dell'america profonda cioè
l'unico museo al mondo degli ufo e
naturalmente in una sezione diciamo
altamente scientifica di questo museo è
questa naturalmente però in new mexico
ci sono anche delle meravigliose riserve
indiane come per esempio quella del
taurus pueblo non potendo diventare
amico degli extraterrestri perché era
una cosa un po faticosa da realizzare
diciamo ho trovato meravigliosa la
possibilità invece di avere dei rapporti
di amicizia e anche di lavoro di
collaborazione con tanti nativi
americani e la mia sorpresa è stata
quella di imbattermi in un mondo
completamente diverso dagli stereotipi
che noi eravamo abituati
considerare intanto sono stati decimati
ma non sono stati affatto terminati oggi
ci sono circa 3 milioni di nativi
americani è un popolo in espansione
demografica e soprattutto in
straordinaria espansione culturale che
ha trovato nell'arte un motivo
straordinario di riscatto e naturalmente
io mi sono occupato soprattutto di
musica anche se il mio rapporto con la
cultura dei nativi americani è nato
invece a un vernissage in south dakota
di un pittore lakota era un vero disagio
un po diverso da quelli che siamo
abituati a frequentare qui non c'era lo
champagne e non c'erano le focaccine
tanto almeno quelle baresi naturalmente
ma c'era il nonno dell'artista che con
un tamburo intonava dei degli antichi
canti tribali
la musica è diventata ovviamente
elemento di grande interesse per me e ho
cominciato a collaborare praticamente
con tutti i compositori nativi americani
in particolare ce n'è uno che mi
interessa farvi ascoltare le abbiamo
anche portato a bari qualche anno fa è
un compositore navaro abbastanza giovane
un artista che che ormai è ospite delle
più importanti rassegne si chiama raven
giacon e la sua è una formazione
artistica interessantissima perché è una
formazione assolutamente sofisticata ma
non è una formazione accademica è un
compositore che forse non saprebbe
riconoscere una sinfonia di brahms
ma questo non interessa affatto la sua è
una musica molto antica ed estremamente
moderna
e vi faccio ascoltare uno strano brano
per otto strumenti a percussione e un
video piuttosto interessante perché
questi strumenti credo suonati da
musicisti perché c'è una partitura
rigorosamente scritta ritmicamente molto
complessa
forse questi strumenti così non li avete
visti mai
devo dire che fu a questo punto
assolutamente inevitabile chiedergli un
pezzo per pianoforte
augurandomi di fare una fine diversa
diciamo dagli alberi del the new mexico
e lui ha proposto un brano
interessatissimo in cui il pianoforte è
questo qui e pianoforte solo
[Musica]
ecco non avrete sentito neanche una nota
di pianoforte ma non c'erano strumenti
elettronici semplicemente che questo
brano è un brano che si basa su un
fenomeno stripes gr feedback si mette un
microfono nel pianoforte questo
microfono genera un suono una specie di
urto di suono originario e io non potevo
fare altro che abbassare silenziosamente
i tasti del pianoforte questo produceva
degli effetti e usare il pedale anche
nella risonanza e attivava questi suoni
assolutamente altri diversi totalmente
diversi da quelli del pianoforte
mi sembrava interessante farvelo notare
per farvelo ascoltare perché in questi
brani c'è anche un fortissimo aspetto
metaforico sono bravi moderni ma sono
fortemente legati alla radice della
musica e della cultura nativa in questo
caso il pianoforte è una natura che non
può essere violentata sulla quale
bisogna semplicemente fare degli
interventi silenziosi e rispettosi di
quello che la natura ci dice è l'unico
brano in cui il pianista non suona ma
ascolta il pianoforte che in qualche
modo suona da solo e trovo che questa
sia una cosa estremamente interessante
ovviamente la violenza in qualche modo
che c'è in questa musica pensiamo a
quella dei fucili e delle pistole per la
violenza che esprime un forte conflitto
questo conflitto c'è anche moltissimo
nell'arte visiva
c'è un altro artista navarro a me caro
che per esempio ha reagito a questa
attrice americana che che si chiama
amico è un'attrice molto famosa che ha
usato secondo lui diciamo insultare la
identità nativa perché in un film si è
messa così forse anche po ironicamente
queste piume e trasformando le frecce in
pennelli si è vendicato con questo
quadro che praticamente una specie di
insulto di deformazione lì le rende come
dire pan per focaccia
io però volevo concludere questo mio
intervento citando un compositore che a
me anche molto caro che è morto undici
anni fa e che si chiama luis ballard qui
avevano anche ai capelli e lui era
ovviamente quello alla sinistra a scanso
di equivoci e lo conobbi appunto ad ad
albuquerque santa fe in new mexico
i suoi nonni fecero le guerre con il
generale custer era veramente un nativo
americano delle riserve ma studio con
darius milhaud con mario castelnuovo
tedesco più grandi compositori diventò
un compositore importante eseguito nella
beethoven haus di bonn delle grandi
orchestre sinfoniche
abbiamo avuto modo di collaborare e mi
interessava diciamo farvelo vedere
perché concludiamo con una piccolissima
piccolissimo intervento musicale che non
è un pezzo di musica ma un esempio la
musica dei nativi americani almeno nel
cinema
noi la vediamo sempre come basata sulle
scale pentatoniche cioè questo insomma
tanto per esser chiari
e un brano molto famoso dei nativi
americani e masin grace che quasi un
inno nazionale dei cielo chi sicuramente
le avrete sentito è interamente penta
tonico e fa più o meno così
[Musica]
bene questa musica che è facile è stata
invece completamente modificata da un
compositore così sofisticato come louis
bard che anche ha usato le scale
pentatoniche ma l'ha fatto in maniera
completamente diversa molto più astratta
molto più colta vi faccio sentire
soltanto l'inizio di un suo brano che si
chiama luce del giorno in lingua
cherokee con basca che fa così
[Musica]
dopodiché la musica si mette diciamo a
raccontare una storia ora ho voluto
parlare di questa cultura perché è una
cultura assolutamente marginale oggi lo
è anche in america
il mio augurio è che come dire questo
spazio che al momento è assolutamente
altro appunto marginale alternativo
quasi spiazzante dell'arte e della
cultura nativa riesca invece ad
affermarsi
perché se lo merita però senza perdere
la sua potenza evocativa la sua carica
rivoluzionaria e soprattutto la sua
capacità di creare ancora delle utopie
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]